bonjour tout le monde alors on va
continuer notre série sur sûrs et
liquides et on avance dans sa carrière
donc là on en 1911 et l'affrontent
vidmar donc joueurs slovènes enfin bon
c'est à hugo c'est à dire un peu à
l'époque qui a été d'ailleurs champion
de yougoslavie
un peu plus tard fin plus tard dans sa
carrière et donc vidmar un bon joueur
qui est un déboucheur 2g pop voire
pendant plusieurs décennies qu'ils aient
eu le titre de grand maître et donc
qu'elle équine encore un donc un jeune
joueur en 1911 qui avait pas encore qui
est encore en même temps et donc il est
confronté à vis de marque
ok alors arrêtez cette partie on y va
donc aller canal et blanc qui jouent eux
400 interview 5
et puis ça va être une partie des quatre
cavaliers tac tac tac tac et il joue le
coup foot b5 donc très bien se
développant les noirs font pareil petit
rock petit rock d3a non justement il a
pris en c6 pardon et oui ce que je veux
dire c'est que maintenant des trois
thèmes le coût principal ici est bon je
n'allais leur font pareil mais
maintenant les blancs ont deux options
soit il continue en clouant le cavalier
est donc en créant la bonnasse caïds et
5 donc les noirs en général ils
échangent ici en c3 qui on prend et il
ya plusieurs manières de continuer la
principale ces dames 7 alors avec l'idée
de libye à la casse des huit pour
ramener son cavalier et chasser le fou
bref voilà ça c'est la théorie actuelle
à noter aussi donc après détroit ici dit
sicilia un plan b sens
qu'yvette andré parrat nand normalement
notamment il ya une pluie ça ou du jour
il ya quelques années en battant de me
dire à anjouan qui a lieu de direct avec
donc l'intention de venir en g3 est de
faire ces trois des quatre ensuite voilà
c'était le petit côté théorique mais ali
qui m'a pris dans ses 6 ok c'est pas mon
revers évident marc prend 2 b alors pas
top
normalement c'est mieux de prendre 2 d
pourquoi parce qu'on veut être si les
blancs prennent l'option e5 pas très
grave les noirs font tour 8 à tête le
cavalier disons qu'ils reculent en
attaquant le fou lena reprennent je
comprends qu'elle valait prend cependant
le 4 mai ouais ok c'est juste égal quoi
par contre donc sur des français si les
blancs veulent être contre un peu
ambitieux c'est plus des trois looks ou
alors ces structures qu'on retrouve
assez souvent maintenant dans des
antilles berlinoise etc mais qui ok pour
les noirs donc là les blancs boîtes à
culture doussain qui est plein de
manières de défendre pour les noirs et
bon il sera tout autre chose alors il a
pris 2 b
les bleus ont pris dans le cinq
évidement un jeu dames 8
bon alors attaque le cavalier veut
reprendre ensuite 4 alors je sais pas
bien pourquoi il n'a pas plutôt préféré
tour est vite ça me semblait ça me
semble plus logique - perso mais ok
dames 8 pas mauvais en tout cas est allé
keane continue par un coût plutôt
typique de son style en direction du roi
c'est à dire qu'ils g4 lequel est
attaqué il le redire ici un coup logique
quand même je pense ses cahiers des
trois on attaque ce fou donc ne reprenne
on prend dix honda me prend 2,4 et on
peut jouer pour eux un petit gain de
temps sur la dame est petit avantage
pour les blancs alors pas grand chose
mais un petit plus bon toujours est il
il a fait kg 4 et on va comprendre
combien sont les déesses qui équiperont
le 4 il veut faire il a fait cavalier h
6 échecs
alors pourquoi parce que sur pions prend
il compte continuer par dame g4 donc il
check et attaque le cavalier alors bien
sûr les noirs ne peuvent pas enfin c'est
pas terrible couvrir comme ça pourquoi
parce qu'il est le fou la balle est donc
on a rétabli qu'immatériel on voit que
la structure noire serait assez ridicule
le roi est faible
on peut soit pour ses options des
nouvelles vous par là soit une autre
option ça serait même de jouer peut-être
avec b3 ou b2 et je sais des bananes
pourquoi pas bon jouer à 10 kg cinq ou
six heures c'est débile mais roy h fuite
dame prend 1,4 et par contre je suis pas
certain qu'on soit tellement mieux si
les noirs jour et par le foot français 3
on doit échanger les dames on reprend et
des hongrois g7 alors je vois bien que
la structure de fusion des noirs est
quand même très moyenne mais mais bon
ils contrôlent la colonne ouverte on a
une finale de foot lors opposer
donc tant qu'elle est tour s'est pas non
plus mais bon en gros les noirs vont
finir développement de blekko tour sur
la colonne a essayé d'échanger toutes
les tours et adulé ça donc à mon avis
c'était une possibilité après ici
pareils dans cette position le faire
[ __ ] en c3 peut-être même accepté de
jouer ça mais bon ça ça peut être un peu
dangereux peut-être en tout cas un point
de vue pour les blancs c'était l'idée
d'aller kim bref donc on en revient ce
coup de café des âges si cela donc après
44 je rappelle qu'ils voyagent seuls les
barreaux fera chaud donc il n'a pas pris
la parole aux rentrées dans cette
position était structure mauvaise les
e-bonds carrière h6 quand même je
pourrai reprendre plus tard tour un très
bien joué sur le clouage dessin qui a
été joué et d'être en donc les blancs
menacent dé prendre quatre et ouais là
dessus sûrement une faute par david mark
a joué tableau 5 qui doublait un petit
truc ensuite calé qui n'a pas bien vu
il fallait à mon avis et lorgues
confirme c'est prendre s'étrangle parce
qu'en fait on ne peut pas vraiment aller
prendre 8 parce qu'il ya des gens qui y
prend dames et ya pas de maths du
couloir parce que le fourbe et 4 fait
son job et défend la tour donc on arrive
dans une pièce ouais on est trois à
quatre fois au but se reprendre on
attaque à la fois
le loup est à la fois la dame et donc
éventuellement fawcett retour alors
c'était pas fini un damage 5 pouvez
suivre encore une fois de par manière
tactique on empêche g prend 1,6
puisqu'on aurait dans le cinq échecs et
on tape le fou mais peut-être que l'état
peut faire un truc comme comme chose 6
est ok en fait l'idée d'aller keynes
était c'est être continuée par affi 4
ici pour faire arrive ça qui est quand
même je exceptions en face de la dame
est bon ça restait pas supra clair
voilà c'est l'énarque karine jouer et
peut-être un coup comme est ici ou quoi
pour échanger les dames et cetera et
cetera mai
mais par contre une nouvelle fois ainsi
givrage six dames 5 échecs
puis hier 5 au projet ils ont rangé 85
et quand même ce roi un peu faible et
c'était bien dans le style avec in
c'était quand même un très bon attaquant
ok alors on en revient à la partie des
trois les bains ont fait des dames 5 et
après des preuves son idée c'était de
faire des quatre mais c'est ce qu'il a
fait dans les partis il se dit ok
pourquoi pas je me lasse plus on prend
ces trois jeux menace pourquoi pas
l'autre là bas donc c'était ça le truc
mais à trois joué très très bon en fait
pourquoi parce que
bon bah si il faut à 5 on va faire des
quatre ont enlevé les cloisons sur la
tour et comme dans la partie il a pris
en c3 prison des quatre prises en b2 et
là un petit coin ça veut dire c'est
super sympa quel point m 7 le truc c'est
que tu reprends n'est pas possible à
cause des maths du couloir dam des huit
combattants de l'inde a mis huit dames
prends toi fuite ça me prend adieu donc
ça c'est obligé et maintenant il fait
tout bien
donc le truc c'est que si les noirs
venait à prendre en c1 bon bah les
blancs prendra ça et si on compte on a
20 affirme plus meilleures structures
superfinale quoi donc les normes pas
vraiment envie de leur entraînement il a
pris là et les blancs au prix en vélo
donc toujours pareil un pion de plus
bon certes les footeux leur opposer mais
justement toujours posé favorise le
crâne qui attaque et si on compare les
deux rois nous on a nos trois pions
devant le roi noir par contre en a que
deux il ya peut-être des problèmes par
là le fou qui tape ici c'est ce qu'aime
avantages des ventes ça en plus de
l'avantagé matériel alors oui mesdames
g5 d'hommes des 3 lille et tours éviter
bon enchaînement des fois je crois au
caire infosys food et 4 on regarde un
peu à cette là bas kim faiblesse
pourquoi pas obligé par tour à un jour
et puis on pourrait faire torah 5 et
doubler les tours etc etc autour des 8
ok clouage en empêche donc ali qui ne
veut bien jouer ce genre de finale
évidemment qui est plutôt à son avantage
ce cas il a quand même ceux qui ont
passé qui avancera tout le tard donc on
ferait 4 et 5,5 6 comme plan en fait en
général mais en plus il y avait cette
faiblesse là bas peut facilement
attaquée peut-être que la tour peut
naviguer paris s'y attaquer aux six
options
bref c'est pas génial comme fiable pour
les noirs il a gardé les dames mais
c'est pas top non plus bien sûr donc
vous prend à 7,24 c3 bien donc très bien
le 7 juin ici il va aider le foie
revenir
et ça lui fera un socle pour rester au
mieux d'échiquier bloquer la colonne des
eaux noires et viser le roi fou des
quatre retours tour à 8 d'amener le bon
je passe un peu vite les cool ce pass
soirée spéciale mais l'on tourne un peu
amélioré leur position tour à 4 bon si
tu veux on échange
donc en plus on a pris la position de
cette colonne et on pourra rentrer quand
on veut d'ailleurs c'est chose faite
cette dame a deux attaques la tour la
toile set d'un match 5 la défense d'un
v6 et on commence à s'infiltrer dans le
roi devait alors en plus au passage que
y avoir des petites combines comme n'en
faut et fin bon alors pas très dangereux
c'est juste faux pas prendre le fou quoi
si on prend les normes attraits comme ça
mais je pouvais faire un bon son idée et
éventuellement il y aller je trouve
qu'on va tout c'est peut-être fier ici
et peut-être des échecs sec
bon juste il y aura pas sale tour à cinq
dames d 1h 2 et donkey tente le fameux
sacrifices mais après avoit prend damas
trois échecs revient finalement men
orbite à trac ward et chaque puisque
s'ils font damien on prend les
simplement en âge d'être le roi et tout
est protégé plus d'échec il fait tour
être quatre
[Musique]
wallace pas grand chose en fait tous
khalid tour a fait retour g4 de détroit
et un dernier coup sont pas touré fuite
pour dévier la tour f 7 de la protection
du mat ici et il ya eu abandon bon d
journal attaque et il ya des menaces de
maths de partout on attaque la tour et
on a une pièce de plus voilà si les
toros at on sait juste d'arriver cinq
échecs g6 forcé et matelas dont bonne
petite victoire d'ali keane et voilà
donc c'était une de ces parties notable
outre un bon joueur de l'époque donc en
1911 qui le place comme un dieu qui
crédibilise un peu ses performances
d'avant allez on se retrouve bientôt
pour de nouvelles aventures et kelly
king